[Music]
in desperate times new law doesn't
measure submitted by Ice Ice Baby and
fellow Indian villagers have been
sending their elderly off into forests
to receive government compensation what
like they get paid for hiking what it is
it's kind of like those uh fundraiser
walks you know I mean like the breast
cancer yeah like you if you do eight
miles then you get paid this much are
they sending them away to die that's
that that's what I was thinking
go into the forest accuse in India India
dirtily respect their elders or maybe
there's a retirement home within the
woods
ah the fourth look at Hansel and Gretel
Indian style and our house is made out
of curry oh we hate that what are they
trying to do so what government
officials found out is that a lot of
people have been sending their elderly
into these forests that are that are
reserved for Tigers and so they're
sending them in there so they can get
mauled so they can get government
causing India what the sigh if they died
out are they still getting those
benefits or are they just getting like
just crawls to the face just enough so
they can say he got heart
yeah they expecting death or like a
miner in our is the worst way to [ __ ]
die but we said this Indian people are
the darker Chinese that's all thank you
so do it's pretty true this is a classic
treaty true it's pretty true because I
watched a Slumdog Millionaire you ask me
and thank you teacher
that's one of my city true ideas of
India is a Slumdog Millionaire and
remember that thing where they had all
the children amputated body parts and
they would have them go out and beg
I know blind that [ __ ] dude I was like
dude that's so next level I don't even
think of that it's not a long time one
moment later they [ __ ] have no limbs
and they beg until there
at bola
I'm not exaggerating that's like legit
what they do there's a guy when I went
to a restaurant and I came out he
started doing this and I came out still
doing it
the pattern I learned some Taiwan make
the ones here look lazy as [ __ ] up and
you make sure not want to get anybody
money here because they work [ __ ]
hard over there and they understand
their position they're like I don't work
for money but I'm begging you to please
have pity on you you know why it's
because Asians are cheap as [ __ ] hell
to get a penny out of the agent you have
to do like so much work you got to be
like please I need I just want the lunch
you want a [ __ ] lunch guess what I
want to lunch too and I [ __ ] work
that's why it's hard to get immigrant
people that give money to homeless
people yep could they get angry they're
like I came here with only $50 in my
pocket and I had to suck so much dick at
work at a Chinese restaurant for me to
make 50 cents an hour why don't [ __ ] are
you homeless exactly yep yeah so this
reserves they're saying that they've
been receiving a lot of Tiger attack
reports recently and so they started
investigating into the and then so once
they they would see like evidence of a
mauling they found out what is the
evidence I [ __ ] in dentures and like
broken Walker's like pieces of clothing
or blood and then like bait so there's
one suspect and they found that this
body was moved outside of the reserve
originally they found evidence that this
person got mauled inside but if they get
mauled inside the reserve they can't
receive any government compensation
because these tigers they're roaming
free so anyone that enters that reserve
it's your fault it's your fault but if
you get mauled outside of the reserve
that's when they can get compensation so
what they found is that someone moved
the body of this elderly person and so
that's when we started investigating
some more and then they started asking
the villagers nearby if they were doing
this and instead of denying it they
ended up saying well these elderly
people volunteered to end their life
earlier so like that's their reason do
you think they really volunteered as
tribute so then the whole village can
eat because that's one
honorable [ __ ] I think I could do that
Jim oh wow aging and then my whole
village is like we haven't eaten in one
week guess we all starving then and I'll
be like I know I'm kind of hungry too I
would start shooting my own commercials
putting slides on my face donate one
dollar here another goes so far if India
trash it would be that I don't know how
to do any action my own commercials
that's absurd as [ __ ] dude yeah this is
one farmer that said quote they think
that they may think that since they
can't get resources from the forest this
is the only way their families can
escape poverty what do you mean they
can't go in the forest and like pick
some mangoes and [ __ ] cuz there's too
many Tigers that's what's happening it's
it's like a reserve I don't know if they
can't even get anything from the port
that's why people be huntin Tigers man I
mean can they farm or something what we
Hockley they can't just fire it's too
hot it's pretty sad that they have to do
all these crazy tactics just to get
money for food I can't even fathom that
level of poverty can we just send them
send them like a whole [ __ ] assignment I
know because like you know how like we
have our [ __ ] struggle stories being
lower middle class boo-fucking-hoo right
and I hear these stories of like you
know like I was a child soldier and they
forced me to kill other people at the
age of seven and they gave me some
[ __ ] gum powder mixed with heroin and
told me to snort that [ __ ] [ __ ] but
you know what now I'm in America and I'm
going to college and I'm like looking at
them like damn dude I'm a [ __ ] I'm
saying it's hard for immigrant parents
to empathize with their children that's
why that's why they always [ __ ] make
you feel like a piece of [ __ ] you know
you know I had to walk ten miles to
school uphill I don't even ride a train
we're not even going to have opportunity
to tell our kids that you know that I
had to come [ __ ] uber
to Washington I waited 10 minutes
because it was so busy that we can't
even fortunate enough to be in poverty
when I was a kid don't you two did not
have enough misfortune so I could give
them a little [ __ ] name yeah and your
[ __ ] face kids your dad didn't have
[ __ ] you know like you think that's what
happens when you Americanized because
you know like if you hear all these like
white people immigrant stories like the
Irish or whatever it's very it's all
similar to every single immigrant story
like they were in poverty they didn't
have potatoes they had to come to the
u.s. they were [ __ ] starving they
were working in the coal mines all this
year right and then their kids get a
little bit easier they go to college and
then their kids and then their kids and
their kids and their kids and then all
of a sudden they're [ __ ] complaining
about their child lattes and warm enough
yield grandpa was searching for the pot
of gold for 20 years before he died and
that was this [ __ ] again yeah I think
that's going to be [ __ ] my grandkids
man my grandkids going to [ __ ] start
complaining about [ __ ] iced coffee
didn't dude I really wish there wasn't
that study that proved that beating your
kids doesn't do anything I wish it was
the opposite but it showed that beating
your kids does improve them as human
beings cuz I she's [ __ ] me up in the
head because I download the article and
do some Photoshop check it out because I
really want to push my kid though what
at least once there your kid you own
time delivery yeah but you know it's
like psychologically anything for them
you don't want to do it exactly play so
wait what what do people do if they
don't beat their kids like hey just talk
to them like a lot I feel like
discipline relationship starts at an
early age you know because when I see my
cousin talk to his kid he doesn't have
to hit his kid but the kid respects him
enough they make they become more
intelligent yeah and as I take go to the
corner of these you know here they go to
the corner he's like keep things like
the whole world is going to add Michelle
tell Denny the kids three now oh yeah
because like he said he spanked him once
and this was such a little plug he
spanked him once he hit him in the butt
he'll they could go to the room right we
spent them in the butt and I suppose
he turned around he started crying some
people so bad that he it is good
language in he had like jacket like it
could be felt terrible believe this
vector kid probably well can I beat your
kids yes cool I might do the little like
up to a certain age like this and don't
do that yeah I cannot so Mike you know
imma put pads and gloves on I'm like
we're [ __ ] goin homie you don't know
how to walk yet but I don't give a [ __ ]
come on crawl [ __ ] overcooked a
[ __ ] baby just kidding kids are
[ __ ] 70 soon oh let's rattling then
fine turn and we're naked [ __ ]
top rock you're trying to dislocate the
arm is so [ __ ] like still like linen
did you ever spank Isaac ah a little bit
you're Mexican I mean I think it's
likely silver belt mexic by the chakra
was sandals and I don't want to be in
Germany I mean I don't I think that's
just different types of parenting like I
say I'm not going to want to spank my
kid but I feel like I'm going to but I
don't want to do it to the extent that
my dad did read through a championship I
will see that's how kids become soft I
bet you that Irish immigrant used to be
get drunk and beat the [ __ ] out of his
and his kids said I'm not going to do
that and maybe I'll just spank in a butt
and then his kid said I'm gonna [ __ ]
not do any of this and I'm just going to
talk to my kids and then they just keep
going down the line like that and
there's no anger issues no they just
soft doors at home but the thing a of a
soft person than someone with [ __ ]
PTSD they're gonna get run over by the
world that's a problem so now they're
complaining about the chai latte not
being hot enough I decide my balance
okay balance yeah because I I agree like
I see Isaac's gang sauce and I'm just
like saying it wasn't one of you [ __ ]
ass up no I'm not saying I want him to
do that you've been elevated that kid I
saw him bro I'm going to hug him up no
that's why I can't even talking and like
it wasn't bad soon as the three of us we
work as a team to parent and so
you're in thinking dude that's that's
like a threesome but like not even
sexual
that's correct oh yeah yeah threesome so
we're like trying to look into putting
them to some martial art so then at
least third person can give them like
different kind of discipline because he
gets discipline from Casey and I at home
and then he I don't know what his dad
usually does because he tells me one
thing will you be doing another so I
don't know what kind of discipline is
getting over there and what I should put
a bit more time okay because I I don't
like when he was younger and he was a
toddler yes like the Mexican mother and
me really truly came out but like as
he's gotten older and like he
understands better and I can actually
possible when there are many undersea I
can understand [ __ ] now I don't need to
resort to Mexican extra [ __ ] money
what do you consider off-limits like
let's say the kids talking [ __ ] got
girls doesn't matter
oh you can flat but if I pick them up by
the neck now that's awesome it what
okay well let's let's put it like this
then I haven't even soft them yet I'm
the kid I'm the kid right and I look at
Bart and I'm like [ __ ] you dad or what
if the kid is like [ __ ] you mommy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's so cute [ __ ]
[ __ ] can I go legit honors why you make
it sound like it's day and night
yeah okay speaker [ __ ] I'm a grown
[ __ ] man all right I'm [ __ ] 12 get
the [ __ ] out of my face they've written
happen like y'all know that room fun no
you don't can't go crazy sometimes look
we're gonna get out of my room balls and
start recording [ __ ] Uncle Joe does
whatever he's wearing a pirate hat right
now I don't think I don't think it
happens overnight like that but what's
wrong with the UH the good old I think
it's so cute I would have I think I
think [ __ ] up is because I guess it's
what kiss starts [ __ ] yelling at me
like that little boy in the diapers I'm
grown I move you know that was just so
[ __ ] cute and funny I would want more
of that
I get mad I'm gonna hate you hey look
you know like you
[ __ ] on hey Linda you know listen
that kid I want to [ __ ] yes awesome me
you guys I watch it and laugh at it like
crazy what it is when I was about your
child as the isolated incidences funny
it's actually gonna make me laugh though
when I saw that [ __ ] I was like I'm a
[ __ ] knock this kid out dude listen
that's funny [ __ ] [ __ ] is rolling
like that what if we had a mom I don't
want to hear she's not [ __ ] crazy you
don't make any sense I sound crazy I'm
asking you what the [ __ ] you want the
room to back your crazy ass up I sent a
question and I didn't even commit to it
again I'm not going my [ __ ] room well
I have a white kid now yeah well he's
privileged now I'm cause of my image at
all if you going to do this with the
same next yeah like [ __ ] mama died hey
guys I hope you enjoyed that episode of
just kidding News and if there's a story
that you guys want us to talk about go
ahead down into our description box
below and there's a link there where you
can submit articles for the next video
click right up here
[Music]